to celebrate the release of Mad Max fury
road let's take a look at 12 things you
probably didn't know about the
post-apocalyptic sequel fury road didn't
start life with a traditional screenplay
instead right and director George Miller
created a visual story with comic book
artist Brenda McCarthy who after seeing
Mad Max 2 in the 80s co-created the
comic freak wave which he's described as
Mad Max go surfing with the help of
storyboard artists Peter pound and Mark
Sexton Miller and McCarthy created the
movies visual first draft a storyboard
with 3,500 panels which covered the
conference room walls of Miller studio
and helped him film and edit the movie
shot by shot before production started
George Miller created an online resource
about the world of fury road for the
movies cast and crew the secure website
included videos of stunts tests costume
fittings and the histories and
hierarchies of each of the movies tribes
in the post-apocalyptic world of fury
road everything has to be reused and
repurposed so to make sure they got the
right look for the movies props the
production design team used real Salvage
materials for example they use soda cans
tires and inner tubes to make weapons
melted down old tank codes and trophies
to make car accessories and 350 salvaged
cars two-part build and customize a host
of vehicles furiosa's mechanical arm was
designed and built by industrial
designer Matt Boog who used salvaged
materials such as spanners parts of car
engines and a motor from a toy airplane
for added mobility a lighter version of
the arm was also produced for Charlize
Theron and her stunt double a core team
of 65 stunt performers brought to life
in wharton joe's army of war boys to
really get into their cultish characters
the stunt performers took part in drama
workshops with actor and fury road
co-writer Nikola Thoris as well as doing
intense fight training
George Miller got the idea for the war
boys aerial attack team the polecats
after seeing street performers balancing
on polls former Cirque de Soleil
performer Stephen bland helped put
together a team of gymnasts to play the
polecats once up in the air
the polecats got their cues via
earpieces and laser pointers on the
vehicles high tensile steel which is
strong but has some flexibility was used
for the polls and each 30-foot pole was
counterweighted with an engine block at
the base which was pushed or pulled by
the vehicle stunt team allowing the
polecats to glide through the air
Australian musician iota who plays the
doof warrior wrote and recorded his own
war tunes which he plays on a double
necked electric guitar as the frontman
of the crazy band whose music rallies
immortan joe's troops to help the bands
taiko drummers keep their tempo amid the
noise of engines and combats the music
was piped to them via earpieces to get a
sense of their personalities George
Miller asked actresses auditioning for
mortem Joe's five wives to read a scene
from any film or TV show
except fury road choices included a
Monty Python scene which was picked by
first-time actress Abby Lee to prepare
to play the five wives Lee and fellow
actors Rosie huntington-whiteley Riley
Keough zoe kravitz and Courtney Eaton
spent three weeks in Sydney rehearsing
and working with fury road co-writer
Nikola Thoris and choreographer Meryl
tankard as background for their
characters they also researched violence
against women in war zones with
playwright Eve Ensler who's worked with
female rape victims in the Congo at the
peak of filming there were over 1700
crew members working on pure erode and
an average of 1000 people on set at any
time the production's base camp was the
size of three football fields and during
120 days moved six times to move gear
from one location to the next they
needed five 8x8 former German military
transport trucks
to create fury roads wasteland the
filmmakers needed a location that was
flat had sand and canyons and little
vegetation originally they wanted to
return to Broken Hill in the Australian
outback where they shot Mad Max 2 but
two years of high rain format the area
was too green however Namibia in
southern Africa had everything they
needed location wise including the
coastal city of swakopmund which
provided the production hub and the
Namib Desert which had the range of
looks required for the road war fury
roads Citadel was actually a series of
sets constructed in the midea Sydney in
Cape Town and its base was built of sand
and fake stone however the Citadel's
towers and surrounding views were
computer-generated the rock walls were
made using high-res photos taken of
Australia's Blue Mountains which were
digitally cursed and bent to form the
shape of the Citadel Australian
motocross champ and freestyle coach
Stephen Gould
helped put together a team of expert
freestylers to play the rock riders who
prowl the canyon a series of ramps and
rollercoasters were built to aid their
movement around the steep canyon walls
filming took place and the midea SWA
Copper River Valley and the size of the
canyon was increased with CGI well there
you have it 12 things you probably
didn't know about Mad Max fury road now
let me know in the comments below what
did you think of the movie and what
would you like to see happen in a sequel
if you enjoyed this video do please
share it hit the thumbs-up button and
subscribe for more things you didn't
know as well as movie reviews and
interviews thanks for watching
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers